tonight more than 200 years after a
former colony won the right to determine
its own destiny the task of perfecting
our union moves forward it moves forward
because of you it moves forward because
you reaffirm the spirit that has
triumphed over war and depression the
spirit that has lifted this country from
the depths of despair to the great
heights of hope the belief that while
each of us will pursue our own
individual dreams we are an American
family and we rise or fall together as
one nation and as one
tonight in this election you the
American people reminded us that while
our road has been hard while our journey
has been long we have picked ourselves
up we have fought our way back and we
know in our hearts for the United States
of America the best is yet to come
I want to thank every American who
participated in this election
whether you voted for the very first
time or waited in line for a very long
time by the way we have to fix that
whether you pounded the pavement or
picked up the phone
whether you have an obama sign or a
romney side you made your voice heard
and you made a difference I just spoke
with Governor Romney and I congratulated
him and Paul Ryan on a hard-fought
campaign
we may have battle fiercely but it's
only because we love this country deeply
we care so strongly about its future
from George to Lenore to their son myth
the Romney family has chosen to give
back to America through public service
and that is a legacy that we honor and
applaud tonight
in the weeks ahead I also look forward
to sitting down with Governor Romney to
talk about where we can work together to
move this country forward
I want to thank my friend and partner of
the last four years America's happy
warrior the best vice president anybody
could ever hope for Joe Biden
and I wouldn't be the man I am today
without the woman who agreed to marry me
20 years ago
let me say this publicly Michelle I have
never loved you more I have never been
prouder to watch the rest of America
fall in love with you too as our
nation's first level
sasha and malia before our very eyes
you're growing up to become too strong
smart beautiful young women just like
your mom and I'm so proud of you guys
but I will say that for now one dogs
probably enough to the best campaign
team and volunteers in the history of
politics
with us
the best ever
some of you were new this time around
and some of you have been at my side
since the very beginning but all of your
family no matter what you do or where
you go from here you will carry the
memory of the history we made together
and you will have the lifelong
appreciation of a grateful president
thank you for believing all the way to
every Hill to every Valley you lifted me
up the whole way and I will always be
grateful for everything you've done and
all the incredible work that you put in
I know that political campaigns can
sometimes seem small even silly and that
provides plenty of fodder for the cynics
who tell us that politics nothing more
than a contest of eagles or the domain
of special interests but if you ever get
the chance to talk to folks who turned
out at our rallies and crowded along a
rope line in a high school gym or or saw
folks working late at a campaign office
in some tiny County far away from home
you'll discover something else you'll
hear the determination in the voice of a
young field organizer who's working his
way through college and wants to make
sure every child has that same
opportunity
you'll hear the pride in the voice of a
volunteer who's going door-to-door
because her brother was finally hired
when the local auto plant added another
shift you'll hear the deep patriotism
and the voice of a military spouse who's
working the phones late at night to make
sure that no one who fights for this
country ever has to fight for a job or
roof over their head when they come home
that's why we do this that's what
politics can be that's why elections
matter it's not small it's begging it's
important democracy in a nation of 300
million can be noisy and messy and
complicated we have our own opinions
each of us has deeply held beliefs and
when we go through tough times when we
make big decisions as a country it
necessarily stirs passions stirs up
controversy that won't change after
tonight and it shouldn't these arguments
we have or a mark of our liberty and we
can never forget that as we speak people
and distant nations are risking their
lives right now just for a chance to
argue about the issues that matter the
chance to cast their ballots like we did
today
but despite all our differences most of
us share certain hopes for America's
future we want our kids to grow up in a
country where they have access to the
best schools and the best teachers a
country that lives up to its legacy is
the global leader in technology and
discovery and innovation with all the
good jobs and new businesses that follow
we want our children to live in America
that isn't burdened by debt that isn't
weakened by inequality that isn't
threatened by the destructive power of a
warming planet
we want to pass on a country that's safe
and respected and admired around the
world a nation that is defended by the
strongest military on earth and the best
troops this this world has ever known
but also a country that moves with
confidence beyond this time of war to
shape a piece that is built on the
promise of freedom and dignity for every
human being we believe in a generous
America in a compassionate American in a
tolerant America open to the dreams of
an immigrant's daughter who studies in
our schools and pledges to our floud
to the young boy on the south side of
Chicago sees a life beyond the nearest
street corner
to the furniture workers child in North
Carolina who wants to become a doctor or
a scientist an engineer or an
entrepreneur a diplomat or even a
president that's the that's the future
we hope for that's the vision we share
that's where we need to go forward
that's where we need to go
now we will disagree sometimes fiercely
about how to get there as it has for
more than two centuries progress will
come in fits and starts it's not always
a straight line it's not always a smooth
path by itself the recognition that we
have common hopes and dreams won't end
all the gridlock or solve all our
problems or substitute for the
painstaking work of building consensus
and making the difficult compromises
needed to move this country forward but
that common bond is where we must begin
our economy is recovering a decade of
war is ending a long campaign is now
over
and whether I earned your vote or not I
have listened to you I have learned from
you and you've made me a better
president with your stories and your
struggles I returned to the White House
more determined and more inspired than
ever about the work there is to do and
the future that lies ahead
tonight you voted for action not
politics as usual you elected us to
focus on your jobs not ours and in the
coming weeks and months I am looking
forward to reaching out and working with
leaders of both parties to meet the
challenges we can only solve together
reducing our deficit reforming our tax
code fixing our immigration system
freeing ourselves from foreign oil we've
got more work to do but that doesn't
mean your work is done the role of
citizen in our democracy does not end
with your vote America has never been
about what can be done for us it's about
what can be done by us together to the
hard and frustrating but necessary work
of self-government that's the principle
we
this country has more wealth than any
nation but that's not what makes us rich
we have the most powerful military in
history but that's not what makes us
strong our University our culture are
all the envy of the world but that's not
what keeps the world coming to our
shores what makes America exceptional
are the bonds that hold together the
most diverse nation on earth the belief
that our destiny is sharing that this
country only works when we accept
certain obligations to one another and
the future generations to the freedom
which so many Americans have fought for
and died for comes with responsibilities
as well as rights and among those
love and charity and duty and patriotism
that's what makes America great
I am hopeful tonight because I've seen
the spirit of work in America I've seen
it in the family business whose owners
would rather cut their own pay than lay
out their neighbors and in the workers
who would rather cut back their hours
than see a friend lose a job I've seen
it in the soldiers who reenlist after
losing a limb and in those seals who
charged up the stairs in the darkness in
danger because they knew there was a
buddy behind them watching their back
I've seen it on the shores of New Jersey
in New York where leaders from every
party and level of government has swept
aside their differences to help a
community rebuild from the wreckage of a
terrible storm
and I saw just the other day in Mentor
Ohio where a father told the story of
his eight-year-old daughter who's long
battle with leukemia nearly cost their
family everything and it not been for
health care reform passing just a few
months before the insurance company was
about to stop
I had an opportunity to not just talk to
the Father but me this incredible
daughter of his and when he spoke to the
crowd listening to that father's story
every parent in that room had tears in
their eyes because we knew that little
girl could be our own and I know that
every American wants her future to be
just as bright that's who we are that's
the country i'm so proud to lead as your
president
and tonight despite all the hardship
we've been through despite all the
frustrations of Washington I've never
been more hopeful about our future I
have never been more hopeful about
America and I ask you to sustain that
hope I'm not talking about blind
optimism the kind of hope that just
ignores the enormity of the tasks ahead
or the roadblocks that stand in our path
I'm not talking about the wishful
idealism that allows us to just sit on
the sidelines or shirk from a fight I
have always believed that hope is that
stubborn thing inside us that insists
despite all the evidence to the contrary
that something better awaits us so long
as we have the courage to keep reaching
to keep working to keep fighting
America I believe we can build on the
progress we've made and continue to
fight for new jobs and new opportunity
and new security for the middle class I
believe we can keep the promise of our
founding the idea that if you're willing
to work hard it doesn't matter who you
are or where you come from or what you
look like or where you love it doesn't
matter whether you're black or white or
Hispanic or Asian or Native American or
young or old or rich or poor able
disabled gay or straight you can make it
here in America if you're willing to try
I believe we can seize this future
together because we are not as divided
as our politics suggests we're not as
cynical as the pundits believe we are
greater than the sum of our individual
ambitions and we remain more than a
collection of red states and blue states
we are and forever will be the United
States of America
and God's grace we will continue our
journey
and remind the world just why it is that
we live in the greatest nation on earth
Thank You America
you